[Musique]
ce soir cinq candidats quatre grands
thèmes son économie vous présente le
débat économique de la campagne
électorale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était là pour vous et maintenant
c'est à vous de choisir les décisions
que prend votre gouvernement maintenant
vont définir l'avenir dans lequel vos
enfants et vos petits enfants vont
grandir
je suis fier de présenter le plan de
rétablissement du canada les
conservateurs vont créer des emplois
augmenter les salaires rétablir
l'économie est écoulé près les finances
publiques notre plan c'est le seul plan
qui dit on ne doit pas mettre la
pression sur les épaules des
travailleurs
on ne doit pas couper l'aide aux gens
notre troisième option c'est de
s'assurer que les ultra-riches paie le
juste pas la seule formule acceptable
pour le québec dans les champs de
compétence du québec c'est de nous ne
part de l'argent il arrange toi avec les
eaux le canada peut devenir une leader
mondial sur le plan de limiter le
réchauffement à
939 global
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à ce débat il ne reste
que quelques jours à cette campagne
électorale quelques jours pour prendre
votre décision faire votre choix lundi
prochain le 20 septembre jour de
l'élection nous vous présentons ce soir
le débat économique de la campagne
électorale quatre thèmes l'inflation et
coût de la vie finances publiques la
dette et les déficits changement
climatique et énergie et puis emploi et
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
avec nous les cinq candidats des cinq
principaux partis pour le nouveau parti
démocratique alexandre boulerice pour le
parti conservateur vincent duhamel pour
le parti vert du canada luc jolicoeur
pour le parti libéral du canada mélanie
joly est pour le bloc québécois gabriel
sainte-marie avoue 5 bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir merci on sera de participer à ce
débat économique avec nous également
andréanne st-arnaud bonsoir on va vous
retrouver tout au cours de ce débat bien
sûr pour présenter les différentes
grands thèmes qui on va commencer tout
de suite je pense avec la priorité des
canadiens le coût de la vie ouais
absolument parce qu'il ya de plus en
plus de canadiens qui ont l'impression
de ne pas en avoir moins dans leur poche
et c'est pas seulement une impression
les produits les services qu'on achète
effectivement coûte de plus en plus cher
on a un taux d'inflation en fait qui est
un sommet depuis mai 2011 gérance et 3,7
pour cent le taux d'inflation au canada
en ce moment
effectivement c'est assez vigoureux
qu'est ce qui augmente les prix
augmentent le plus par exemple dans
certaines catégories les sens évidemment
on a peut-être un petit rattrapage
depuis le creux et de l'an dernier la
messe est presque 31 % les véhicules
automobiles cinq et demi pour cent le
logement presque 5% les aliments presque
2% certains produits évidemment les prix
augmentent encore plus alors ça c'est
pour les dépenses au quotidien si vous
voulez mais il ya d'autres gros morceaux
dont les prix ont explosé et l'on pense
à l'immobilier par exemple pour
quelqu'un qui souhaiteraient acheter une
propriété une habitation unifamiliale
on a franchi la barre du demi million de
dollars à montréal augmentation de 17%
depuis un an un million quatre cent
vingt-trois mille dollars et remonte au
21 % d'augmentation et c'est plus d'un
million 800 mille dollars à vancouver
20% d'augmentation on parle de coût de
la vie faut parler des tarifs de
garderie qui sont élevées à 1 au québec
c'est ça il ya beaucoup de pression sur
les jeunes familles dans ce budget
mensuel combien ça coûte chaque mois
évidemment je vais vous présenter
quelques villes dont montréal où on a
accès aux centres de la petite enfance
c'est beaucoup moins cher c'est 180
dollars par mois mais winnipeg 451 $
montaigne une gradation comme ça 716 $
edmonton 950 dollars par mois pour faire
garder un enfant d'un gouvernent et 165
$ toronto presque 1600 $ ça met beaucoup
beaucoup de pression sur le budget des
ménages merci andriole en attente au
premier thème donc le coût de la vie
tout coûte plus cher et les gens veulent
des solutions pour chaque segment le
débat est ouvert mais on a fait un
tirage au sort pour déterminer à qui la
première question est posée dans chaque
bloc donc c'est vraiment le hasard moi
je suis là pour poser des questions pour
relancer le débat pour m'assurer que
tout le monde peut parler et surtout
qu'on les comprend les cinq encore une
fois merci d'être avec nous et la
première question ce soir c'est à
gabriel sainte marie qui va briser la
glace je sainte marie avec la forte
hausse des prix pour tous les biens et
services énumérés depuis tantôt quel est
votre meilleure solution pour freiner
l'inflation
la plupart des économistes avaient
prédit qu'au lendemain de la pandémie il
y aurait une forte inflation et qu'elle
serait temporaire il faut regarder ça
attentivement par pia beaucoup
d'inquiétude nous notre premier souci
c'est pour les uns un an le coût de la
vie augmente puis les passions le
pouvoir d'achat augmente pas donc ça
fait déjà un certain temps qu'on propose
d'augmenter la pension de sécurité de
vieillesse de 65 ans de 110 dollars par
mois pour faire face justement cette
hausse de coûts là c'est des gens qui
ont un pouvoir d'achat qui est
fragilisée il est temps qu'on s'en
occupe alors priorité aux aînés
dites-vous je vais relancer mélanie joly
tout de suite là dessus les mesures pour
soutenir les aînés sont généralement
au-delà de 75 ans dans les propositions
que j'ai fait et dans le dernier budget
également entre 65 et 75 mélanie joly
est ce qu'on a oublié cette partie des
aînés absolument pas parce que justement
on propose d'augmenter le supplément de
revenu garanti pour les gens de 65 ans
et plus de 500 $ et pour ceux qui sont
en couple de 750 $ et en même temps on
sait que les gens parfois veulent rester
plus longtemps la maison donc on est
prêts à faire en sorte de leur offrir
une aide jusqu'à 1500 $
je vous dirais que sont la question de
l'abordabilité parti libéral un plan
très fort que ce soit au niveau du prix
des maisons vous en avez parlé en
réalité référence ou six pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un système universel
de garderie au pays on a mis 32
milliards sur cette question là
justement dans le dernier budget et si
tu ne nous promesses les plus
importantes de la campagne avec moins
d'un dollar par jour pour les couples
entre 65 et 75 ans si j'ai bien compris
ce que vous proposez nous on a fait nous
on a fait en sorte justement d'aider nos
aînés de différentes façons tout au long
de la pandémie c'est vrai que le 16 août
dernier et 75 ans et plus ont reçu un
chèque de 500 dollars mais en même temps
on a fait en sorte contrairement aux
conservateurs de ramener l'âge de la
vieillesse de 67 à 65 ans et on avait
également augmenté par le passé le
supplément de revenu garanti à plusieurs
on abolit l'immobilier le prix des
maisons est extrêmement important il a
explosé surtout dans la dernière année
est ce que vous avez une mesure vincent
durel par exemple pour les jeunes
ménages les jeunes ménages qui veulent
avoir accès à la propriété une mesure
qui va changer leur vie de toute une
série de mesures qui ont été mises en
place sur tout pour augmenter l'offre le
problème qu'on a au canada c'est une
question d'offre problèmes qu'on a eus
aussi celle là elle et les étranglements
les goulots d'étranglement qui ont été
causés par la pénurie par trop d'argent
qui était mis dans le système avec les
libéraux au cours de la dernière année
et demie une inflation comme on a en ce
moment c'est une taxe surtout pour les
plus démunis alors l'offre des
conservateurs est vraiment d'adressé ce
point là en premier et s'assurer que les
plus démunis se retrouve pas avec des
logements qui sont pas robe de se
permettre un accent boulerice
je venais sur le tableau qui a été
montré au début sur l'inflation c'est
quand même intéressant de voir que
briser notre dépendance aux combustibles
fossiles c'est aussi une manière de
lutter contre l'inflation mais
évidemment pour la majorité des ménages
puisque j'entends le des familles vie
des gens à montréal du partout au québec
c'est le prix des loyers le prix des
maisons a explosé les gens sont plus
capables de payer sa de suivre les
hausses alors nous on a un rattrapage
dont un plan pour rattraper la
construction de logements sociaux et
abordables et les logements sociaux si
la meilleure manière de sortir les gens
de la pauvreté de leur donner une
dignité et c'est aussi une manière
d'avoir du logement hors marché qui
diminue la pression sur le marché
immobilier et ça c'est quelque chose que
les conservateurs et les libéraux se
sont traîné les pieds pendant des années
qu'on a payé le prix aujourd'hui
directement malheureuse luc jolicoeur
comment on fait baisser comment on aide
les gens à retrouver un meilleur pouvoir
d'achat avec la poussée d'inflation
qu'on connaît nous on se préoccupe
beaucoup des jeunes qui ont des prêts
pour excuser d'important à rembourser ça
c'est un point essentiel on se préoccupe
du logement social n'y a pas
suffisamment de logements sociaux il y
en a pas eu suffisamment de construire
ces logements là doivent
écoénergétiques et faut se préoccuper
aussi du revenu général des gens en un
programme qui est un revenu minimum
garanti pour aider les gens à passer à
travers les circonstances difficiles de
la vie on va y revenir là-dessus
d'ailleurs à savoir si on a les moyens
de faire ça je veux vous entendre sur
différentes idées qui ont été proposées
depuis le début de la campagne
électorale le parti conservateur propose
notamment de permettre aux entreprises
étrangères américaines de faire
concurrence à vidéotron bell telus et
rogers au canada pour amener plus de
concurrence
qui répond à ça est ce que c'est une
bonne idée de faire ça ça déjà monsieur
fillion salle a déjà été essayée par
l'examen conservateur des années à
reuters elle a pas donné de résultats
probants nous ce qu'on dit ou npd s'il
faut réglementer les frais d'accès
internet et les coudées facture de
cellulaire il ya moyen de le faire on le
fait déjà avec un organisme parapublic
pour les médicaments on peut faire la
même chose les familles s'ouvrait le 500
à 1000 $ par année avec ce qu'on propose
nous autorisent ou insultant le défi le
défi avec cette mission lorsqu'il faut
le financer quelque part et si le
financement de ça ça va venir évidemment
des taxes de problèmes qu'on amène au
canada c'est qu'on avait déficit hors
contrôle on a des taxes hors contrôle on
n'est pas capable de continuer à
investir pour les canadiens c'est là le
grand défi le problème d'inflation qu'on
discute en ce moment c'est trop d'argent
qui court après trop peu de bien
qu'existe faut augmenter l'offre des
biens et non pas juste réglementé qui va
racheter la démocratie qui va rendre au
canada comme moins attrayants comme
place d'accueillir les investisseurs la
question a mal présentement c'est
vraiment qu'est ce qui doit couper parce
que là on sait déjà qu'ils coupent dans
les transports en santé et transparent
santé augmente seulement partir de la
cinquième année c'est à dire à partir du
deuxième poteau jeudi c'est moi terminé
s'il vous plaît monsieur jamel l'autre
chose aussi c'est que dans le fond ils
tentent de faire en sorte de faire des
économies sur le dos des maires des
parents au pays parce qu'elles coupent
la promesse du parti libéral du
gouvernement libéral de faire en sorte
de créer un système universel de
garderie et donc de créer une place pour
250 mais le travailleur de plus au
canada donc c'est l'équivalent de
d'empêcher une croissance de 1 point 2 %
notre économie c'est l'équivalent
d'empêcher de la création d'un an à
l'ena parce que c'est le même et
factuelle l'accord de libre échange ale
pas sur les finances publiques on va y
revenir d'ailleurs mais puisque vous
parlez des garderies ça coûte quand même
très cher les garderies on avait les
chiffres tantôt est ce que les canadiens
méritent un système de garderie le même
qu'au québec partout au canada pour ne
pas entendu gabriel st paris par exemple
ouais ben moi j'aime bien content qu'on
l'aï au québec puis si ottawa choisi de
financer un programme mais je pense que
le québec a droit à sa part et dans ce
cas aussi vraiment inspiré du modèle
québécois mois la crainte que j'ai c'est
dans quelques années le pour l'instant
une entente qui a été signé 6 milliards
transférer sans condition mais dans deux
ans dans cinq ans dans dix ans est-ce
qu'il va avoir être qui va être encore
sans condition on connaît la propension
du fédéral à mettre son nez d'un champ
de compétence du québec des provinces
soit il y en est pas question monsieur
tu vas 2005 c'est juste un contenu de
plus jeune fils a pris cinq ans au
québec à maxi garderie deviennent
disponibles on ne peut pas s'attendre on
ne peut pas attendre cinq ans c'est sûr
quand même qu'on met en place est
vraiment d'aider les familles les plus
démunies maintenant à pouvoir reprendre
marché du travail on a besoin de donner
la flexibilité aux pères et aux mères de
famille pour pouvoir faire l'édition que
doit faire pour leurs propres besoins et
les besoins à montréal où les besoins
dans d'autres villes en saskatchewan en
concoctant que ce ne sont pas les seules
provinces à décider elle même
c'est un crédit d'impôt remboursable
monsieur vous quand même lire dessus je
suis dure époque on reçoit au début du
système c'est le même système que le
québec au fait en 2008 un saumon du
conte qui avait pas ces places en cpe
pour accélérer l'accès à des places en
donnant les crédits d'impôts est ce que
les conservateurs proposent de france
c'est la même chose que le sujet au
coeur et madame joly insurgés le cas
rapidement ce qu'on a besoin c'est un
système universel le système universel
aux canadiens nous ont bien servi le
système au québec fonctionne bien y'a
pas de raisons pour n'aurait pas le même
système à travers le canada les gens
payent 1500 $ et plus en garderie à
toronto c'est inacceptable si en un
système privé on va voir un crédit
d'impôt il ya beau et remboursables et
couvrira jamais ce montant là donc ça
fonctionne pas la proposition des
conservateurs
même si je lis car ledit façon très
éloquente je suis d'accord avec lui
c'est important que par une sorte qu'on
respecte l'entente de 6 milliards avec
le gouvernement logo qui va permettre la
création de 37 mille places en garderie
pour compléter le système ici c'est ce
qu'on a besoin y'a pas une femme
enceinte au canada présentement qui se
pose pas la question qu'est ce qu'elle
va faire avec son enfant au moment où
ils vont vouloir attendre je
veux vous avez
donc juste au moment où elle veut
retourner sur le marché du travail
c'est l'automne marché du travail dans
cinq ans peut-être que ça peut marcher
si vous respectez vos promesses mais le
problème c'est cette la femme enceinte
vont pouvoir retourner probablement dans
la prochaine année ou la prochaine année
et demie on a besoin d'avoir un système
en place pour cette personne là
maintenant et quitter le gouvernement
martin à l'époque avait proposé un
système universel de garderie le
gouvernement en faveur des conservateurs
a été lui qu'est ce que vous avez fait
de l'effet tenseur de spira paix
l'entente entente qu'on avait à l'époque
c'était madame joly si c'était si
important pour vous pourquoi vous l'avez
fait deux mois avant les élections vous
avez pu le faire il ya six ans et je
vais donner le dernier mois monsieur
boulerice pour ce bloc là vous en pensez
quoi monsieur voudrait écouter le vieux
truc là de distribuer un peu de largeur
des chèques des conservateurs en pensant
que les solutions et du duel marche
mieux que les services publics ça
fonctionne pas le système des cp au
québec est une fierté et aux proches on
pense qu'on doit le bonifier c'est une
bonne entente et les conservateurs ce
qu'ils nous disent ce qu'ils veulent
déchirer un chèque de 6 milliards de
dollars au gouvernement du québec qui
aiderait les familles y ont rien de plus
efficace le système de garde public
abordable l'échec la halle et aux
individus sa couv jamais les frais bon
ben vous êtes en forme je pense on va
continuer très bas on s'arrêter pour une
pause sur dans un instant merci
retour le canada doit-il avoir une cible
de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire est
ce qu'il faut taxer les riches stimuler
la croissance on va parler finances
publiques dans un instant
[Musique]
oh
on a un plan d'écouler près le budget au
cours de la prochaine décennie
on doit réduire les dépenses dans une
manière équitable notre dette comme
proportion de la taille de notre
économie continue à diminuer encore plus
rapidement que ce qu'on avait prévu il
ya quelques mois c'est le sait le débat
économique de la campagne électorale
avec 5 candidats des différents partis
deuxième crainte est maintenant des
finances publiques le gouvernement est
dans le rouge andréanne on pourrait même
dire le rouge foncé et pour longtemps et
dois je vous rappeler que le
gouvernement était déjà dans le rouge
avant cette pandémie en fait au cours du
premier mandat des libéraux on va vous
présenter les chiffres là c'était une
cinquantaine de milliards de dollars de
déficit 2019 2020 c'est l'année où on
compte quelques semaines du début de la
crise la fin mars donc le déficit pour
cette année là 39 milliards 400 millions
et pour l'année évidemment 2020-2021
c'est l'année de la crise 354 milliards
de dollars et s'en sortir de cette crise
là ça va être long le directeur
parlementaire du budget chiffre l'impact
sur les finances publiques pour les
prochaines années y aura encore des
déficits importants 138 milliards de
dollars pour 2021 2022 47 milliards de
dollars l'année suivante et ça diminue
progressivement mais voyez vers la fin
de l'échéancier de cinq ans je vous
donne quand même autour de 25 milliards
de dollars donc pas de retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire si on continue au
rythme actuel et ça que ça fait en sorte
que la dette s'accumule les derniers
chiffres du directeur parlementaire du
budget remis aux parties pour la
campagne font état d'une dette qui
pourrait atteindre cette année presque
1200 milliards de dollars
le ratio d'endettement la dette par
rapport au pib wii va fondre va passer
de fondre recul et disons le passé de 51
2% à 49 2% mais le directeur
parlementaire du budget dit on devrait
quand même avoir un ratio d'endettement
supérieur au niveau d'avant la pandémie
pendant une trentaine d'années les
canadiens craignent que ce soit un
fardeau pour les prochaines générations
des chips très clair merci andré en
empruntant tôt vincent du mlc t'avoue
que la première question de ce blog
s'adresse d'abord et avant où je dois
mais est-ce qu'il faut absolument que le
prochain gouvernement qui dirige le
canada ne dirige avec en tête un retour
à l'équilibré budgétaire
j'ai survécu un tsunami j'ai survécu un
tremblement j'ai survécu la pire crise
financière asiatique dans mes années ou
que je passais en asie je connais sol et
les crises et surtout les sorties crypte
et le plan qu'on voit en ce moment
devant nous des libéraux c'est
finalement s'est dépensé sans compter
six contes moraux maudit la semaine
dernière un autre débat sur la fiscalité
pendant la pandémie on a aussi mal géré
les la pandémie en période pandémique au
juste cette scic intéressante que je
garde de ce matin on est le pays que
dépenser le plus en comptons pib 15,60
son pib pour la pour la pandémie la
corée est celui qui a dépensé le moins à
nu pour ça mais vous si vous n'êtes pas
si vous êtes juste ce n'est pas ce que
c'est important d'être le compte est
quand même à la question là je suis
d'accord je veux me rendre à la question
ne peut pas confier à laizy rapidement
le point les coréens ont eu quatre morts
quatre décès par 100 milles les
canadiens ont eu 71 décès par 100 ml on
se retrouve dans cette situation que
tout ce qui a été fait par les libéraux
c'est juste de lancer de l'argent après
de l'argent savoir à gérer à cibler pour
se rendre vers un environnement plus
responsables ont uniquement si c'est
difficile 0 il faut ramener vers un plan
pour se rendre là on a deux chauffeurs
des départs je pense au parti
conservateur et c'est un point qui est
extrêmement important contrat je vais
laisser mélanie joly répondu écoutez
vous savez le coût de l'inaction aurait
été plus grand que de faire en sorte
d'avoir un plan qui en faisait mans et
vous savez on était là pour protéger les
gens avec leur santé oms 9 sert un filet
social puis on a fait en sorte aussi
d'éviter les fermetures d'entreprises
pour être en mesure de protéger les
emplois d'ailleurs toutes les mesures
qui sont mises en place présentement la
grande majorité lors de la première
année de la pandémie ont été soutenus
par tous les partis devant vous alors
dans les circonstances je pense qu'on a
été capable de travailler oui en
collaboration mais aussi on peut pas
dire qu'on a dépensé l'argent par les
fenêtres parce que tous les partis
étaient d'accord fait jeudi s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'il faut avoir les
déficit zéro en tête dans le prochain
mode mélanie joly le plus important
c'est créer de la croissance économique
le plus important c'est que
l'augmentation des revenus continue
alors qu'ils ont fait en sorte bien
entendu de s'assurer que cette
augmentation la soie plus sommes plus
grande que l'augmentation des dépenses
but parce que lorsqu'on regarde si on se
compare aux états unis on a déjà
récupéré 95 % des emplois près pandémie
aux etats-unis sont à 76% donc on voit
que les investissements qu'on a fait a
permis une plus grande relance
économique et il faut continuer pour
faire en sorte que ça soit je pense que
ce sujet si faut faire attention parce
que là certaines mesures comme la pca
heureux peut nuire justement au retour à
l'économie nous on le voit le jeu
d'aller voir des des centres d'emploi
tous se disent les gens nous disent on
va continuer à voir notre pci quand ça
sera fini on va retourner travailler un
point dans ce débat aussi concernant l'
équilibre des finances publiques c'est
nous on s'intéresse l équilibre des
finances publiques pas celle d'ottawa on
le sait le directeur parlementaire du
budget a publié une série d'études année
après année qui montrent qu'il ya
déficit qui est beaucoup plus important
auprès des provinces donc s'il faut s'en
préoccuper le conference board va dans
le même sens je comprends mais satisfait
aux demandes nouvelles élections
fédérales vous avez présenté un cadre
financier ou trois ans alors que notre
monde présente des cadres financiers sur
cinq ans jusqu'à riquet justement
jusqu'à quel point les finances
publiques fédérales intéresse le bloc
québécois et c'est hyper important sauf
que quand leur présenter votre
spécialiste serge coulombe l'économiste
de l'université d'ottawa dit que c'était
assez fragile de prévoir sur cinq ans à
ces moments incertains moi je pense
qu'il faut miser sur une relance
importante je pense que le 21e siècle
c'est l'économie du québec on pense
transports en commun énergies vertes
ressources naturelles on savoir si
ottawa donne un bon plan 23e lien c'est
un sujet pour
le sujet il ya un sujet pour les
élections l'année prochaine à québec
nous autres qu'on demande c'est quand ta
voix finance les infrastructures
un point c'est tout si ottawa veut
arrêter de regarder le xxème siècle
puisse tourner vers l'avenir je pense
qu'on a tout pour réussir dans les
sujets que j'ai nommé alexandre
boulerice vous êtes au npd le plus
dépensier des parties 214 milliards de
nouvelles dépenses en cinq ans mais vous
êtes le parti qui prévoit la baisse la
plus importante de la dette par rapport
au pib dans cinq ans comment ont réussi
cet exploit ont réussi cet exploit
regardant non pas seulement les dépenses
les investissements parce qu'on a une
stratégie d'investir dans les gens pour
réparer notre société notre filet de
sécurité sociale d'un système de santé
publique mais on regarde aussi là où est
l'argent c'est là où se distingue de
tous les autres partis qui sont autour
de cette table c'est à dire qu'on a le
courage de dire les gens qui ont plus
que 10 millions de dollars de fortune on
voit les imposer voilà donner une taxe
de 1 % de plus les gains en capitaux ils
vont être posées par juste à 50 % de la
recette les revenus mais à 75 pour ça on
va s'attaquer aux paradis fiscaux puis
on va augmenter les impôts des grandes
compagnies qui ont fait beaucoup
d'argent pendant pendant la pandémie
donc ici si on veut régler nos problèmes
sociaux si on veut prendre soin des gens
il faut aller chercher l'argent là où il
est malheureusement les conservateurs
les libéraux ont pas eu le courage
d'aller faire dans les dernières
décennies mais c'est sa l'engagement du
npd et puis et puis de jazz médecine
c'est à dire on va créer une société
plus égalitaire plus équitable et plus
juste mais paul
des mesures sérieuses
monsieur fillion fait déjà dans le fond
on demande des gens pleurer sans faire
le plus on le fait au cours de nos
souris mandat mais aussi ce qu'on
demande c'est que les taxes sur les
banques les institutions financières les
compagnies d'assurance qui ont bien
bénéficié bank dont les parts des jeux
ou encore aujourd'hui rémy première
chose deuxième chose on demande à ce que
les géants du web en fasse plus haut si
on demande à ce que l'un pour ça
également en phase plus et on va
investir dans l' agence de revenus pour
contrer l'évasion fiscale donc c'est la
façon la plus responsable tout en
assurant qu on puisse continuer à avoir
des investissements au canada parce
qu'on sait que pour la croissance
économique c'est important qu'on puisse
en mesure qu'on va être en mesure
d'avoir plus d'endroits et
d'investissement monsieur duhamel est ce
que c'est possible de traction les mieux
nantis et les entreprises au canada d'un
côté on pourrait taxer son suel
l'argument du npd on pourrait taxer
tacaille est à l'ont taxé confisquer les
100 plus grandes fortunes au canada ça
représente havrais 335 milliards de
dollars on va les taxes est au complet
ça vaut même pas payer la moitié des
déficits accumulés ne m'attendais
le point qu'on fait ici c'est juste ça
s'appellerait même pas la moitié des
déficits accumulés depuis les
libéraux sont au pouvoir s'était refusée
important de parler de création de
richesses pour ensuite la partager
l'emphase du parti conservateur c'est
vraiment
monsieur joe 2 pour ses chevaux je pense
à la création de richesse on augmente la
taxe
si vous voulez je sais pas mais dans mon
cas c'est ça toujours été ça ça a
toujours fonctionné comme recette de
cris la richesse de permettre l'accueil
et la recette plutôt que de jeu il a
répondu je me laisserais pas possible
rapidement très rapidement cessé de la
pensée magique du côté conservateur
parce qu'ils disent on va baisser vos
impôts on va augmenter les dépenses puis
on va atteindre le déficit zéro on n'y
arrive pas
vu de baisser les impôts
des années harper pendant des années la
[ __ ] absolument pas fonctionné c'est
un retour en arrière
jolicoeur le parti vert vous proposer un
revenu minimum garanti de 10 mille
dollars par année qui coûterait 81 5
milliards selon le directeur
parlementaire du budget puis vous voulez
aussi éliminer la production pétrolière
en 2035 c'est 18 milliards de revenus
fiscaux en moins pour l'état vous prenez
ou les revenus pour compenser tout ce
joli car oui on s'attaque aux paradis
fiscaux on s'attaquait l'évasion fiscale
on augmente les taxes pour les
entreprises au niveau comparable à ce
qui existe aux états unis donc on n'est
pas dans la démesure l'on avait quelque
chose de très raisonnable et le déficit
qui m'inquiète moi c'est le déficit
qu'on laisse aux prochaines générations
projet en termes de dette non à terme de
dégradation de notre environnement et
saufs aussi attaqué les oui ça coûte de
l'argent mais ça va ça va aussi créer
des 800 emplois sont en train de relance
verte ou au canada monsieur fillon les
dégâts il ya une question qui est
importante parce que le parti
conservateur s'est engagé non seulement
faire en sorte que l'entente de 6
milliards du gouvernement logo sur les
garderies tombe mais également à
renégocier la péréquation avec jason
kenny en alberta alors essentiellement
ce qu'ils disent présentement il est
très préoccupant pour le québec que il y
aurait donc ceci milliards de l'ofppt le
sec 14 milliards de péréquation que le
québec reçoit donc un rêve de 20
milliards dans le budget québécois ils
sont les très près je me suis djamel ben
non c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est qu'on va
s'entendre pour essayer de renégocier
pour s'adapter à la nouvelle réalité
compte entre 1 vie madame jolie madame
joly semble penser que les pois
centralisateur d'ottawa vont pouvoir
décider pour tout le monde sur
l'ensemble du canada nous ce qu'on dit
c'est chacune des provinces ont leurs
propres compétences qu'on doit
s'adresser travailler avec eux en
partenaires vont être capables d'arriver
avec la solution globale pour l'ensemble
du canada entre autres comparses de
dette on doit parler de dette fédérale
et provinciale parce que les deux sont
très associe l'une de l'autre et la
situation est beaucoup moins bonne que
ce que prétend mais surtout docu sainte
marie oui ben justement c'est le temps
de donner un coup de barre puis ottawa
depuis les dernières années voir les
quelques décennies qu'on vient de passer
ne joue plus son rôle dans les
transferts du financement de la santé
notamment puis il ya un important
rattrapage à faire toutes les provinces
québec toutes les provinces demandent 28
milliards la demande à ottawa de payer
35 % du coût de la facture c'est ce que
nous confirme le directeur parlementaire
sonne qui j'en viens je la tue les bains
nous dans notre plateforme laon le mais
on n'est pas les seuls puis je pense est
important de continuer à pousser ça
c'est l'équilibré la viabilité des
finances des provinces parce qu'il faut
que chaque niveau joue son rôle merci
beaucoup c'est deuxième bloc qui se
termine on s'en vont troisième bouger
pour rester là le débat se poursuit dans
un instant retour on va parler de taxe
carbone de marché du carbone
d'investissements verts de voitures
électriques de crise climatique dans un
registre
[Musique]
oh
non
il faut reconnaître qu'au moment le
canada est un des pires émetteur de gaz
à effet de serre a pas remis à les pays
au monde tu les investissements du
gouvernement néo démocrates vont pour
réduire nos émissions pour investir dans
l'énergie renouvelable pour pour faire
ce qu'il faut pour faire face à la crise
climatique
vous regardez le débat économique de la
campagne électorale avec les candidats
des cinq partis représentés à la chambre
des communes on va parler maintenant de
la priorité des canadiens selon notre
boussole électorale les changements
climatiques et andréanne le canada n'a
vraiment pas le meilleur des bilans en
matière de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre je vais vous
montrer l'évolution des émissions
canadiennes depuis 2005 qui est en
quelque sorte l'année de référence le
pour l'établissement des cibles de
réduction alors on partait de sept cent
trente neuf mégatonnes de gaz à effet de
serre émis à ce moment là voyez ça a
reculé progressivement jusqu'en 2009 à
moins de 700 mégatonnes mais par la
suite la courbe est incertaine meilleur
une petite tendance vers l'art aussi
d'ailleurs entre 2006 et 2015 et 2019 ya
eu cette progression on est passé de 700
m3 à 730 mégatonnes le gouvernement se
les fait reprochés
puisque le canada est le seul pays du g7
allait dans la mauvaise direction si on
veut mais tous les partis ont fixé des
objectifs pour la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre au pays des objectivement
par exemple c'est une réduction ciblée
de 30% pour le parti conservateur
ça va de 40 à 45 % pour le bloc
québécois et le parti libéral le npd
vise une réduction d'au moins 50% et les
verts réduction de 60% comment on y
arrive chaque partie à ces stratégies
1001 des outils c'est la taxe carbone
qui rend les comportements polluants
plus cher si vous voulez et selon le
plan actuel la taxe carbone le prix
augmente de 15 $ par année et culmine en
2030 à 170 dollars la tonne est ce que
ce serait suffisant pour changer la
tendance question et c'est ce qu'on va
voir avec nous cinq candidats merci
andréanne c'est alexandre boulerice
maintenant qui va répondre à cette
première question dans ce thème
alexandre boulerice du npd est ce que la
taxe carbone pour vous est l'outil le
plus important pour combattre les
changements climatiques
c'est un outil parmi tant d'autres mais
s'il est seul ou s'il est contredit par
l'ensemble du reste des décisions
gouvernementales que mon neveu libero ça
fonctionnera pas et ça marchera pas ils
vous regardez les chiffres ils sont trop
bas le fait que sous les libéraux le
canada est le pays du g7 pendant les
deux dernières années c'est absolument
inacceptable c'est le plus grand défi de
notre génération de capable de fournir à
nos enfants une planète qui va être
viable il repas des catastrophes
naturelles à répétition des 10 millions
de réfugiés mais va conserver la taxe
carbone c'est au gouvernement il faut
fin de vue-là oui on la conserve mais il
faut en faire beaucoup plus parce que ce
qu'on a vu avec les libéraux c'est
beaucoup de beaux disques aux plus
belles paroles mais des actions
contradictoires on subventionne les
compagnies pétrolières et gazières en
moyenne plus que les conservateurs de
stephen harper et puis on ne tient pas
on est en fait de l'exploration et de
l'exploitation au guardian qui est
pétrolière au large de terre-neuve on a
un paquet de mesures qui viennent annulé
l'effet de la cat la taxe carbone nous 1
[ __ ] on dit il faut mettre de l'argent
dans une banque climatique va servir à
financer des projets carboneutre devons
réduire notre empreinte carbone c'est la
seule chose à faire il faut prendre un
virage radical contrairement à ce que
pense steven guilbeault qui pensent que
ce pôle temps de prendre un virage
radical pour notre il faut agir au parti
vert vous êtes à 265 dollars la tonne en
2030 alors que le plan actuel c'est 170
dollars la tonne en 2030
265 dollars la tonne est ce que 6 août
nomme pour pour les gens la taxe carbone
c'est l'outil le plus important pour
diminuer les émissions de carbone donc
le principe est simple plus tôt m
carbonne plus dupes et de taxes et la
grande majorité des canadiens ne seront
pas aussi inspecté que ça passait aux de
taxe de carbone parce que ils ne mènent
pas tant de carbone dans certains cas
dans d'autres cas ils vont prendre des
mesures en place comme s'acheter une
voiture électrique ou utiliser
transports en commun qui veut venir
réduire
leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc si on veut des résultats ça prend
deux sapins l'outil un moment donné on
ne peut pas avoir le beurre l'argent du
beurre parlant d' outils nous ce qu'on
propose aux blocs pige en supprime pas
mal fial de cette proposition là c'est
un plan de finances verte on le sait
depuis les accords de paris les banques
le secteur financier canadien ont
investi 700 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires
dans les hydrocarbures
nous on dit il faut arrêter ça
maintenant ça prend un plan pour sortir
la finance des hydrocarbures ce qui
dégagerait des capitaux justement pour
la transition c'est pas juste avec les
fonds publics donc l'argent des
contribuables qu'on va réussir cette
mission là il faut mobiliser l'ensemble
du système financier au parti
conservateur voulait plafonner la taxe
carbone qui vous voulez a baissé les
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre en quoi votre plan monsieur
duhamel et crédibles dans un contexte
d'urgence climatique les cibles qu'on a
mis en place sont des cibles qu'on veut
crédible on doit commencer avec sauf les
libéraux ont mis des six puits ont pris
les mêmes sites que monsieur harper
avait nos même pas été capable d atteint
en fait ça s'est empiré l'idée c'est de
ramener vers ces cibles là de se rendre
à les atteindre avant de prendre des
ambitions à se mettre à 40,45 ait changé
d'idée à peu près toutes les fois
dépendant d'eux qui a émis un patient
faut suivre ça mais il faut commencer et
commencer un
bateau qui coule pas combien d'autres
est capable d'enlever tu regarde combien
dont il faut t'enlève monsieur duhamel
mais en fait je laissais me suis dit
enfin terminer je vous donne ma parole
mais la deuxième chose la deuxième chose
en a mis en place un plan un plan d pas
que ça devienne incitatives pour
encourager les gens qui polluent plus à
prendre des étapes à faire des choses
pour s'assurer d'avoir une économie plus
verte c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'essayer de convaincre les gens par un
incitatif que plutôt de prendre un
marteau leur taper dessus pour des
succès comme si vous avez c'est très
répressif surtout pour les plus démunis
qui ont parlé sous sachet de voitures
électriques demain matin madame joly le
canada est le seul pays du g7 à avoir
connu une augmentation des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de 2015 à 2019
pourquoi tout à coup les canadiens
peuvent croire en votre plan après le
constat depuis six ans monsieur fillion
est d'accord avec vous après la pandémie
la plus grande crise qui nous attend
c'est celle de des changements
climatiques est ce pour cela que je suis
fier d'avoir fait partie d'une équipe
d'un gouvernement qui pour la première
fois a mis sur pied la fameuse le fameux
prix sur la pollution dont on parle
depuis le début et qui a fait en sorte
aussi de se battre contre les
conservateurs qui ont non seulement
voter contre mais qui se sont battu
jusqu'en cour suprême pour parents de
l'annuler donc on a un prix sur la
pollution ne plusieurs mesures en place
pour faire en sorte justement qu'on
atteigne aux cibles parce qu'il a fallu
reprendre en fait tout l'inaction qui
avait été causée par le gouvernement
conservateur mais comme je pense à
l'avenir pensons mais le 10 ans à venir
et donc on sait que présentement marchés
financiers ils disent les autres
gouvernement dans le monde investissent
il va avoir une lutte pour faire en
sorte de se tailler une place dans cette
nouvelle relance verte et les
changements va aller très vite dans un
plan ambitieux le plan le plus ambitieux
selon les environnementalistes de tous
les partis on veut faire en sorte de
bâtir l'avion du futur l'autobus du
futur le camion du futur la voiture du
futur que ce soit de lyon électriques
attirent
les meilleurs plans il y avait deux
milliards deux milliards d'arbres
plantés on avait planté huit cent mille
sont très beaux dans les plans mais
incapable de cotation huit cent mille
huit cent mille arbres notre vérif le
vérifier justement en iran des 800
milles sur 2 milliards mais c'est un
objectif dans le temps on y reviendra de
toute façon gabriel sainte-marie vous
alliez dire oui parce que comme dit à
justin trudeau il faut les pousser
les au bloc on avait apporté un projet
de loi pour forcer le gouvernement à
respecter les cibles des accords de
paris-pse a même pas passé
n'a même pas voté pour chaque oeil c'est
des belles paroles madame joly sauf que
c'est trop peu d'actions concrètes il
faut faire plus le bloc leur camp lors
harper était au pouvoir vous n'avez même
pas empêcher les conservateurs de nous
retirer du protocole de kyoto aidants
minoritaire on est sortis de l'accord de
kyoto et la banane on a toujours notre
aujourd'hui
monsieur boulerice qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec trade center
mon dieu quelle mauvaise décision des
libéraux encore une fois qui est dit une
chose qui te font leur contenu fait quoi
on est introduit on est pris avec un
tuyau trois fois plus d'erreurs qui ont
coûté 15 à 16 milliards de dollars aux
contribuables
il faut briser notre dépendance aux
combustibles fossiles donc évidemment il
faut pas continuer
d'exploiter d'exploiter ça en même temps
on veut pas le prendre 15 milliards de
dollars puis le jeter aux poubelles
lendemain matin parce que ça appartient
aux contribuables cet argent là à la
voir là ça soit évaluer quelle est la
meilleure manière de réparer les pots
cassés par les libéraux de justin
trudeau malheureusement on y prie avec
ce n'est pas notre décision mais là ça
appartient à tout le monde peut-être
qu'on pourra le voir question des actifs
la dengue sont valables les vendent à la
pièce à travers le monde vont vouloir
évaluer toutes les possibilités mais
l'idée c'est pas de beaucoup d'hommes
jeunes soient posées de l'exploiter pour
l'amortisseur non non non non ça c'est
ça c'est le plein des libéraux monsieur
7 madrid
contre
les médecins les très clair là dessus il
faut vouloir garder qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ça on peut pas juste prendre le 15
milliards de dollars que vous avez
décidé de dépenser inutilement vie de le
jeter à la poubelle l'idée c'est pas
continuer à l'exploiter quand c'est
juste d'affaires de la baignoire juste
de faire de moins d'argent possible on
est quand même responsable et vous
monsieur duhamel vous gardez 30 mountain
et vous voulez relancer northgate oui il
faut se servir de ce qu'on a pour
s'assurer de pouvoir financer la
transition qu'on doit faire on réalise
est important de faire cette transition
que cette transition climatique la ne va
pas le faire en fermant tout cas en
s'enlevant des ressources qu'on garde
des pays comme la norvège qui ont très
bien fait de se servir de ces ressources
là de toutes leurs ressources naturelles
pour se rendre respectez les sit&go
monsieur je ne
fais plus de nouveaux projets pétroliers
il faut arrêter de faire des nouveaux
projets et il faut diminuer le plus
rapidement possible il faut surtout
diminuer le pétrole à partir des sables
bitumineux qui utilise du pétrole pour
faire du pétrole donc c'est exactement
le contraire de ce qu'on veut faire et
les libéraux ont pas respecté leur
objectif donc sa part message clair faut
que les gens votent pour le parti vert
pour dire l'environnement c'est la pluie
a gagné jeudi avant la pause oui deux
choses ont fait la première chose c'est
qu'on nous on va mettre un plafond sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur pétrolier gazier dont ils sont
anglais engagements clairs deuxième
chose et que j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour mon collègue duhamel qui est avec
nous aujourd'hui mais la réalité c'est
que je m'attends à ce qu'il soit capable
de convaincre son caucus que les
changements climatiques sont réels
parfait alors on va le laisser songeur
pendant la pause on va s'arrêter dans un
instant pour notre dernier bloc dans un
instant les entreprises manquent de
travailleurs quelles sont les solutions
à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre notre
débat se poursuit dans un instant
[Musique]
oh
pour les entreprises des régions du
québec la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre et
rendu un problème majeur c'est pour
annoncer des jobs dont on a besoin c'est
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
dernière partie de notre débat
économique avec cinq candidats à
l'élection de lundi et c'est sans doute
la première élection au certains chefs
pourrait se faire reprocher de vouloir
créer trop d'emplois andreoni deux
grands enjeux le chef de la pandémie
bien sûr et la pénurie mais parce que
c'est vraiment une reprise inégale d'un
côté vous avez des industries qui sont
loin d'avoir retrouvé tous les emplois
perdus pensée tourisme hébergement
culture et on a encore besoin de soutien
et de l'autre côté des industries qui
ont retrouvé leur rythme mais qui sont
freinés dans leur croissance parce qu'on
n'a pas assez de travailleurs voici où
on en est au canada en ce moment le taux
de chômage pour le mois d'août était de
7,1 pour cent on a retrouvé à peu près
les niveaux d'avant la pandémie mais pas
au niveau des emplois il en manque
encore cent cinquante six mille deux
cents à récupérer pour retrouver le
niveau de février 2020 il ya un enjeu
pour le chômage de longue durée sont à
peu près 400 mille canadiens être au
chômage depuis au moins six mois ça a
plus que doublé comparativement aux
niveaux d'avant la crise et pendant ce
temps là vous avez 8 115 mille postes
vacants d'un bout à l'autre du pays on
n'arrive pas à trouver de candidats pour
les combler sa augmenté de 40 %
comparativement aux niveaux d'avant la
crise et en tout c'est à peu près 5 % de
tous les emplois au pays qui ne sont pas
comblés en ce moment ça freine les
entreprises dans leur croissance et ça
nuit à la reprise de l'enfant de
l'économie des données vraiment
spectaculaire merci andré young merci
beaucoup on va poser pour ce dernier
bloque la première question à luc
jolicoeur du parti vert c'est à vous
qu'on pose cette question ce joli coeur
est-ce que vous tenez au parti vert les
prestations d'urgence mises en place
durant la pandémie comme étant l'un des
facteurs principaux pour expliquer la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre en ce moment
pas du tout pas du tout ce qu'a réussi
que les emplois qu'on a de la difficulté
à combler c'est parce que les
travailleurs sont pas suffisamment
qualifiés ou ou qu'on manque de
travailleurs dans certains secteurs donc
on en parle notre système d'éducation on
parle de qualification des travailleurs
on parle aussi de l'immigration qui
peuvent venir combler ce problème là et
on parle de productivité d des
entreprises donc la bonne une bonne
partie des emplois qui qui sont pas
comblés sont des emplois qui sont bien
ri numérique c'est pas vrai que si on
fait mal aux travailleurs on va les
forcer à occuper des emplois l'homme
aime ça marche on a l'impression au bloc
québécois puis au parti conservateur que
la pci mais surtout la paix ses erreurs
en ce moment fait partie du problème
mais sur sainte-marie pourquoi vous
dites ça oui c'est juste un problème de
fond qui étaient là avant la pandémie
qui va continuer en allant à augmenter
il ya deux joueurs qui partent à la
retraite pour un travailleur joue un
travailleur qui arrive donc monsieur
jolicoeur a énuméré plusieurs éléments
considérés mail actuellement on s'en
doute collectivement pour payer du monde
à rester chez eux si c'est parce qu'ils
peuvent pour retrouver leur emploi qui
on veut conserver l'expertisé tant mieux
si blond live mais si c'est pour des
gens qui seraient pourrait retourner à
leurs emplois qu'ils avaient avant
qu'ils disent on a jamais de chez nous à
recevoir ça c'est pas de la dépense et
du gaspillage est ce qu'on sait qu'à
pcrm je voudrais ce
que je tapais sur surpris d'entendre
le bloc québécois le casser du sucre sur
les travailleurs des préjugés qui
ressemblent beaucoup à ceux de la droite
écoutez il n'y a pas eu de pc aux états
unis il n'y a pas de pc erreurs aux
états unis puis ont une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comme nous autres donc c'est un
peu simpliste comme comme comme équation
et puis sérieusement le 6 300 $ par
semaine si un emploi est pas capable
d'offrir mieux que l'équivalent de 7
dollars de l'heure comme conditions de
travail est un problème à regarder au
niveau du niveau des conditions de
travail qui sont aux femmes oui de
l'adéquation avec la qualification de la
main-d'oeuvre comme dit mon collègue du
parti vert mais sinon c'est un petit peu
facile de blâmer la paix ces erreurs
quand on regarde aux états unis à nos
papilles ont le même problème comme dans
son domaine l'apc heureux ajustant venu
miner une situation qui existait déjà
avant la pandémie c'est des initiatives
auraient dû être prises par deux
libéraux il ya six ans plutôt que juste
maintenant où on réalise tout d'un coup
que la courbe démographique du canada
est en train de se modifier et rendre le
canada dont on a besoin de donner
beaucoup plus productif et efficace dans
la façon qu'on génère notre économie le
pib de notre économie le programme qu'on
essaie de mettre en place et surtout de
créer les incitatifs pour ramener ces
travailleurs là pour aider les
entreprises à aller chercher des
travailleurs en payant une partie
surtout les travailleurs que ça fait
plus d'un an qu'ils travaillent port
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour eux
de réintégrer le marché du travail on en
a besoin on a besoin à travers par
exemple le comté où je vois une centaine
d'entrepreneurs se plaint que de ça est
ce qu'un gouvernement libéral madame
joly qui resterait au pouvoir
poursuivre davantage la subvention
salariale aide au loyer la prestation
canadienne de relance économique où on
arrête le 23 octobre comme prévu mais
pour l'instant c'est pour le 23 octobre
ce qu'on a dit par contre c'est que pour
les secteurs touristiques et des arts et
de la culture on n'avait pas en sorte
que la subvention salariale et l'aide
aux loyers se poursuivre pour que l'on
soit en mesure d'être là pour les
travailleurs dans les secteurs qui sont
encore aux prises avec une crise
économique
maintenant lorsque j'écoute mes
collègues ont parlé de la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre moi aussi je l' ai entendu
et il ya deux facteurs qui expliquent sa
mes collègues certains de mes collègues
ont bien exprimé le vieillissement la
population écouté ma grand-mère avait
cet enfant ma mère de trois enfants puis
moi j'essaie d'avoir des enfants donc ce
ses premiers points 2e point jeu dirais
aussi qu'il ya un enjeu au niveau de
l'immigration n'est certainement pas eu
le nombre d'immigrants prévu qu'ils sont
arrivés au canada et en particulier au
québec au cours des deux dernières
années à cause de la pandémie mais
j'espère c'est enfin le bloc québécois
les conservateurs vont voir la lumière
au bout du tunnel et faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un plan d'immigration
ambitieux web et on a besoin du sujet le
sujet je pense que un sérieux ménage à
faire puis un remodelage au niveau du
ministère de l'immigration
l'on parle de délai de 28 mois pour un
immigré économique ça n'a pas de bon
sens s'il fouillis total on a des codes
compter pendant l'élection où il ya des
étudiantes et des étudiants au cégep qui
ont fait leurs preuves de deux permis
effectués sont retournés chez eux les
travailleurs travailleurs étrangers
temporaires il ya 20 de l'inquiétude
tout le processus l' immigration il ya
un sérieux coup de barre à donner est-ce
qu'il faut saisir ces migrants sur
sainte-marie pour atténuer la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre ben c'est sûr que la
question de l'immigration est crucial
lorsqu'on voit le présentement c'est que
des entreprises au québec qui disent on
veut prendre de l'expansion limitées par
les contraintes de l'immigration le
fameux 27 mois ci au dessus de deux ans
donc on prévoit prendre de l'expansion
ailleurs donc je dois
garder absolument ça s'apprend plus
d'immigration pirée rapidement sur la
pcr si on avait eu un programme de
revenu minimum garanti en europe est
obligé d'essayer d'ouvrir il revenait à
gauche après ça à droite puis trop
savoir l'assurance emploi revenu canada
l'eau quand est-ce qu'on peut quel
secteur on qu il faut mettre la
simplicité dans ce système là pour que
les gens qui ont besoin des aides l'aïd
rapidement mais à ce sujet là je peux me
permettre monsieur fillion
ou nous là le revenu minimum universel
c'est intéressant avec les convois les
chicanes en provinces pilotes à voix
c'est compliqué ce qu'on veut c'est con
ça soit le monde ensemble pour rejeter
les nouvelles bases d'un programme
d'assurance emploi qui fonctionne qui
pourrait inclure notamment les
travailleurs ce travailleur autonome dès
le début de la pandémie le système s'est
effondré et là plus que jamais le tas de
la relance et puis il faut il faut
arrêter d'être au niveau de la réforme à
qs world il ya quelques décennies on a
parlé on a évoqué depuis dix ans que la
population en âge de travailler les gens
de 20 à 64 ans
cette population a augmenté de 8% mais
les 65 ans et plus a augmenté de 42%
monsieur duhamel est ce qu'il faut
inciter les personnes de 65 ans et plus
à rester sur le marché du travail et
surtout comment on le fait absolument il
faut créer les incitatifs qui vont leur
permettre de peut être pénalisée si des
restes marché du travail vous préviens
si le marché du travail beaucoup de gens
surtout maintenant on est tous plus en
forme qu'ils sont encore capables de
contribuer énormément vu d'ailleurs qui
veulent contribuer énormément ça fait
partie des engagements de s'assurer que
ces gens là puissent avoir une fois pour
continuer à contribuer
je pense que je revenais de seconde il
faut réparer le système d'immigration
effectivement on perd la main d'oeuvre
de manière systématique les délais n'ont
aucun bon sens sur ans où les libéraux
plus des grands bleus et demi en plus
d'immigrants c'est absolument nécessaire
c'est un grand levier il faut aussi une
réforme de l'assurance emploi les
travailleurs autonomes mais il faut
regarder aussi les populations qui ont
un moins grand taux d'activité sur le
marché du travail et qui ont beaucoup de
jeunes regardons les premières nations
les populations autochtones ça touche -
heureusement petite patrie vous allez
mener madère plusieurs régions du québec
il ya peut-être là une avenue
voir garder un petit peu pour être
capable d'attirer des gens sur le marché
d'une an et j'ai dit oui ben bien
entendu nous on a on s'est inspiré de ce
que le gouvernement du québec faisait on
veut l'appliquer partout à travers le
système fédéral un crédit d'impôt pour
les 65 ans et plus qui veulent continuer
à travailler donc c'est la première
mesure deuxième mesure il va de soi
qu'on doit avoir plus d'immigrants je
suis contente d'entendre de mes
collègues ça doit être le cas alors
lançons un message clair à monsieur
legault parce que c'est important aussi
puisque québec est en charge d'une
grande partie du système d'immigration
de faire en sorte qu'on augmente les
seuils et finalement je vous dirais que
encore et toujours on doit être en
mesure de faire une réforme de
l'assurance emploi pour inclure les
travailleurs autonomes comme mes
collègues du npd et du bloc québécois et
est ce que vous pouvez ce soit ma
dernière question est ce que vous pensez
que un système de garderie bien fortin
l'a tellement expliqué souvent que ça a
mené une plus grande participation des
femmes dans le marché du travail est ce
qu'un système de garderie ce pas
messieurs de vos belles une solution à
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre cette
solution le problème du système de
garderie de le faire on doit avoir des
solutions maintenant est le preuve le
programme de crédit d'impôt qu'on avait
quelques inquiétudes un coût qui est
payé au trimestre avant pour besoin de
le faire à la fin de l'année et pour
s'assurer que les femmes et surtout les
familles les plus démunies puissent le
plus rapidement possible d'avoir les
outils la flexibilité de poids gonesse
marché du travail on peut pas se
permettre d'attendre cinq ans avant que
le système fonctionne
donc oui trente mille nouvelles places
en garderie un programme de garderies
universel ça va faire en sorte qu'il ya
deux cent cinquante mille femmes en
grande partie qu'ils vont être capables
de joindre le marché du travail je tiens
à vous remercier c'est tout le temps que
nous avons passé je pense une très belle
heure ensemble à débattre de plusieurs
des enjeux économiques alexandre
boulerice vincent durel luc jolicoeur
mélanie jeudi gabriel sainte-marie merci
beaucoup merci
aux élections et pour en savoir plus sur
les cadres financiers des partis
fédéraux rendez vous sur radio canada.ca
barres obliques cadre avec un s trait
d'union financier toujours avec un vous
aurez beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
nos collègues du web qui travaillent
fort tous les jours a colligé ces
informations merci encore à tous les
candidats merci à toute l'équipe qui a
construit qui a diffusé cette émission
merci à vous de votre attention bon vote
à demain
[Musique]
passons